well some candidates running for
president right now the Democratic side
are openly promising what they've
privately wanted for years they want the
NRA stamped out they want to ban guns
they may even want to take guns by force
the NRA is the worst organization in
this country I am very much one that is
against handguns and I know in my urban
environment I see little to no need for
guns at all yeah just some national
discourse we don't need guns of course
we need guns you're not allowed to have
guns that's the attitude wealthy
liberals obviously hire bodyguards or
hide themselves away in safe gated
neighborhoods but what about people who
can't afford to do that what what gun
bans mean for people who live and say
Detroit Michigan well this show went to
Detroit to investigate that very
question and here's what we found my
name is Elena Gonville and I live in the
city of Detroit
Elena GaN Ville is an arms Detroiter I
carry my 45 he put in the chamber he
chooses to carry a gun to protect
herself she says her guns helped her
survive an armed carjacking at a liquor
store in Detroit's West Side my armed
with it gone Ville was shot in the arm
during the attack around here she drove
herself to the hospital police never
caught the attackers
and went down it's a pretty girl with
people that stick and they just thought
that they could get me and surprise
surprise
honey the bouncers
stories like hers are why so many people
in Detroit have decided to take personal
protection into their own hands why do
you carry a firearm because I live in
Detroit sometimes it takes a while are
you doing Detroit's Chief of Police
James Craig agrees it only takes a
minute or less for violence that happen
and it's over and that's why Craig
strongly supports the right to carry if
a citizen is armed they have a better
opportunity to staying alive than if
they weren't fishing at issues gun
permits to anyone in Detroit who takes a
class and passes a background check
vaudeville took her fire runs class with
Detroit native Rick actor yeah let's
soon
actors detroit-based gun rights group
name legally armed in detroit has helped
thousands of women get their carry
permits we have a growing number of
women here in Metro Detroit we're
learning more about firearms and what it
takes to defend themselves do you
recommend that robotic systems go out
and get that permit if they're
law-abiding they get to training
absolutely have particularly found
interesting going to classes that are
all female who want who support carrying
concealed weapons the number of permits
has surged in Wayne County Michigan
where Detroit is located nearly one in
every ten people has a carry permit we
have professionals we have housed moms
we have people who are just everyday
normal citizens when criminals pray and
look for victims usually looking for
those who they believe are defenseless
we're talking about women we're talking
about the elderly there's always gonna
be crime it's always gonna be you know
they say the devil came was still
killing destroy and he's not going
nowhere what would happen if the
government illegal to carry a gun
people would still carry I rather my dad
always says I rather be judged by 12
than carried by six is that how it goes
so I mean that's how it goes lady garden
Ville is hardly alone part two of our
series on being legally armed in the
city of Detroit airs tomorrow night good
luck to bado trying to take those guns
away